[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and we are here at ultimate moves one of
our favorite events for the summer of
fast we right here see our founder of
the Chess Club Rex Sinquefield
and I'm Jennifer Tejada I'm in the
studio with jazz and Christian right
here we have Rex's follow Randy Singh
field of course that's Rex's son the
founder of spectrum studios ultimate
moves is all about Rex and Randy having
some fun with the best players in the
world I'm in a giggly mode right now so
excuse me during the show if I break out
into laughter this is fun this is where
the players just get together relax
trash talk to the best of their
abilities and play the ultimate contest
father and son
that's absolutely right yes we don't
have G meeting filled in the mix but if
we did it would just be a white Rex
first ready Rex wearing the red shirt of
course and we have team Rex these are
the players that rex recruited for this
epic match up including Fabiano Corrado
Wesley so Sergei Kuryakin Maxine Bashir
Allegra shocked mummy Darth and Peter's
fiddler who has been our Russian
commentator a lot of people have been
saying they want to see more of Peter
well you get your chance today Carlton
is in town that's right world champion
magnus carlsen
in town specifically for ultimate movies
there's nothing else he's doing here
right yes Mora Levon Aronian a vision on
the legend
Alex agree shook and a linear Dominguez
gold medal winning Olympiad teams on
both sides and the format Jennifer well
the way this will work is we're gonna
have six games of a game five with the
five-second increment after five moves
the teams rotate play
so we're gonna see the same players face
off again and again as the game goes on
the things will begin every 20 minutes
so we're looking at about a couple hours
of fun here and we also have Christian
Carrillo with some insights he's been
stolen away from the Kings iodine our
welcome to the show great Jim thanks
guys I'm super excited to be here with
you and I'm very very excited about this
team matchup who's going to be the
dominant Singh field but most
importantly who's going to win between
madness and Fabiano we're going to see
this today we're going to see this on
the 25th of August in the single Cup
when they meet before London which is
going to be in November and it's going
to be the biggest event of the year so
I'm definitely looking forward to feel
that competitive edge nents between the
two of them every time that Magnus is at
the table Fabiana will be right next to
him which is wonderful for our
photographers Leonard in Austin
offsetting one another but well let's go
to a Maurice Ashley use upstairs to kick
things off at ultimate moves well the
Queen of Soul Aretha Franklin who passed
away today sadly at the age of 76 used
to seeing resp ect well there's gonna be
no respect between the players today as
Rex and his son Randy go added in the
ultimate moves and Rex I know you don't
like to lose the it's a Randy in
anything what are your thoughts about
this game today this match today I feel
sorry for him for the whole team over
there I mean they're good players but
not today the trash-talking started
already Randy you know your father well
and you know that's how he rolls what
are your thoughts about the match today
I think I think yeah the tides about to
change we're due for a win and I won the
first year with Magnus on my team so
yeah I'm feeling pretty good
alright the Singh fields are the sea
fields are excited the players look calm
and relaxed we expect their best
trash-talking to happen during the
competition we're gonna have a lot of
fun naturally let's get the all gets get
all the action started right
hearty handshake to begin this epic
match alright who do you get I'm taking
Rice's team I'm his chess coach looks
good so far I think I think you were
next to traditional well they looks even
even good word so far
let's get Bobby you're on the other side
what do you thought about your position
right now seven but maybe another player
would have picked it
are you criticizing your own teammate no
no Bishop a2 is a perfectly good move I
was just hoping for some more fireworks
but I'm sure we'll find some and Peter
you or commentator during the event
during the rapid enlist now you're a
player what do you thoughts about
sitting in on the this is the fun I'm
not enjoying any of this yeah oh I need
to be back in the basement what am i
doing we have two other players coming
up it was the Russian commentator for
our rapid and blitz stream up against he
karlin/des Kimura
he's also the Russian champion so he's
not out of the game
yes I'm scheming the game intensive what
do you thought
I'm just looking at them and I mean that
the class that they're producing
especially from the white side is
extraordinary very I'm very proud of the
white players to get this position so
early on it's an achievement the sarcasm
my sister says what are your thoughts
about the vines response you guys are
good friends well I mean yes right with
my a white players I actually respect
blacks play so far I mean but one thing
is the time country is definitely too
slow I'm getting bored all right
gained any advantage for the white
players but what they treating there was
less behind Fabiano did you see it was a
stocking Teemo and and you were saying
that Magnus is going to meet the Fabiano
but it seems like they challenged that
decision
exactly they're not going to face each
other they don't want to to do that
today they want to wait
keep us waiting indeed but of course
LaVon was was mocking the fact that
white got nothing out of the opening and
I got to give credit to team Randy
because last year team Randy had a lot
of issues in the opening and it seems
like he worked on that part of his game
and doing a lot better today the
training is paying off that's right we
will see when they come back but for
their next moves because then the
pressure will truly be on but what was
this this was a pawn sacrifice what the
heck
Oh Queen take the d3 94 was the great
idea I suppose shaded what is he
sacrificing palms when is rent Rex and
Randy coming in after they go through
the whole rotation so he says we have to
be right move 30 or so we have Maxie
masters for each squad trying not to
appreciate it should be moved 35 okay we
need to make these players what do you
what do you think about this pawn
sacrifice
it's a sacrifice that wish will benefit
from LaVon explaining that the sacrifice
was needed don't believe anything he
says today yeah exactly
never trust the on the ball okay black
spawns have been shattered it's an extra
life and I think the night is going to
reroute the three 500 now we've got em
BL and BL pleaded out the French versus
well invested you know about investments
I know you like the world as you know
he's just trying to be nice yes it's
like why are these players mess up my
position is antiquated
Boyd is a rookie five will envy I'll see
it as he goes up against nine times
world champion by the way this year none
he good SIA
I asked fishy at dinner last night is
I've been misinforming everybody that
you're a five-time world champion and he
said and I said that's not true how many
World Championships said he won the
World Junior he's won the Fisher random
World Championship he's won the Blitz
he's wrong won the rapid there's not a
title in the in the chess world that he
has not won I like what this is doing I
like the move 97 and open up the a file
put the bishop force the bishop on v1
which is not a very strong diagonal and
right now he's trying to control the
e-file I think he's going to do it and
it's attacking pawn on c5 it's not doing
anything else so I like what Anand is
day and he's reducing the amount of
material in the position potentially may
be a rookie fight now so that when Rex
and Randy get back to the board their
decisions will be a lot easier
[Laughter]
on the white side of a pond down and
exactly
forgive the king of what are you feeling
about this position you haven't even
gotten a chance to play yet I hope I
will play some moves
if I move every time last okay we're
gonna switch out and maybe the last one
to play or maybe never get to play so we
have what black is doing creating this
sort of brocade we denied on d6
supported by the by the structure this
is a big moment should he played B 5 B 4
before allowing like that opportunity
and he's done it I thought that was a
good move that night keeps White's King
kind of boxed in he's a pretty decent
player you think I hurt really yeah and
by the way we are trying to get you the
mics when the players start talking but
when they're not talking we're fully in
so we're gonna do our best for everybody
watching we get somebody at the board
trash-talking no would you ever play a
fight and with the King on f6 or is that
just about
the strategical decision I definitely
put the pond on an age idea is very
clean to the center Russian
trash-talking happen right now after a
careful preparation we have to put the
pond on h6 get that point off the lights
work and then I think at the right
moment please see for the White team may
go down and fishes in such a case well
we have Rex and Randy coming
I'm afraid a few moves yeah trademark
g4g pipe seeing in the rapid and blitz
g4 was the trademark move of Shaq can't
stop no but what do you think Wesley
sounds like he's counting on Randy to
come back in this year finding a really
nice way of advancing his passer that's
up to the arbiter I'm not involved on
rules arbiter bleed
has he done white oh yeah everyone's
okay she's gotta get in their fight
against the Grandmaster
if I just take on June 14 things before
and then she you nervous that Randy's
gonna sit down now he's really been
working on his chess and why is that
whoa big time move there Knight d6 whoa
not going for any races Wow so Rex and
Randy's back now he's got the chance to
take the knight and go into a kingdom
punting game and it's a dead win for the
black side I think the fight
[Applause]
shouting now Randy promoted his public
amenity for pressing the clock not
falling for the seat bill blender
although apparently according to arbiter
crisper that no longer is an application
is only a warning
- nd steam first game to finish that off
no I think Randy did almost everything
Andy did bring it home Randy how are you
feeling let's get ready how do you
feeling finish thinking that one on I
told you the tides have changed ties to
turn baby I'm I'm feeling good so let's
do this I'm ready for more victory goes
to team Randy and Rex
I gotta get a word from you that was not
your best effort no but you know we're
warming up it's gonna get better all
right guys 1:02 Randy will throw it back
to you well let's take a look at the
standings after that epic blunder
getting off with the bang with the
victory it's it's key nothing in that
game yeah nothing out of the opening
they actually ended up you know much
worse position and then of course the
blunder which gave quite no chance yeah
it was a smooth performance the training
I spoke to Randy before the match he
told me that 12 months you know the
intense workout and he was ready and
fabbi babby with that pawn sacrifice
that never paid off that was awful what
was he thinking that wasn't on Rex I was
terrible Christian that quick that key
moment you've got it up on your board
show is where it went wrong for Team Rex
no absolutely 92 is just an inviting
move in this position of course you're
suffering a little bit as whitey don't
have as much space and wishbone a two is
quite secluded but you should probably
play this move Knight wait three and try
to finish this
and this way not 92 92 is just inviting
this grabbing of a pond and simply
putting you don't have enough
conversation and I'm going to give it to
Thema Randy they made a wonderful job
out of their extra palms so kudos to
them pretty impressive and LaVon said
that he really appreciated the white
team play and because he captured the
prong with the light and let's go up to
Maurice Ashley and get a game to kicked
off well the players are excited at
least one team is I get a thoughts on
the first game from Levon Aronian this
was a very very good game played by
Randy and we're just executing his plans
succeeded and on the other side we get a
thought from Fabiano Caruana
that wasn't the best effort yeah it
didn't go too well from the opening
unfortunately we gave Ruxin
unsalvageable situation but 96 was a
star before the game that was very very
good all right well the action is about
to start let's get ready for Game two
and they're underway shadow he also
plays an accelerated line of the
Sicilian oh so he's gonna be feeling
comfortable as Rex and out of this
opening I feel the preparation I think
these guys have specifically prepared
for this battle
the maroc seemed bye bye Randy that was
impressive thank you for great choice by
Randy no he got
well played by us Magnus is going to be
very pleased having the light side of
our rugs we're seeing some classical
positions coming from the very beginning
been studying chess every day I think he
wants to say he's ready for the
classical about now he wants to play
Randy what you've got into great
position so far for your players what's
the deal usually you've made a slight
off move already yeah that was
experimenting last year I think this
year we'll just you know stick by that
keep it by the book he's not gonna
appreciate it is she getting into the
trash-talking as well there Jennifer
Bishop e2 stopping that 94 idea I like
that smooth cast wings there by the
world champion
[Music]
things are quite a job I really expected
more trash-talking at this point you
know deep think and I think they changed
the strategy as well they mix up some
lineup yes yes it was Wesley it was
Wesley who is second that's the last
name now yes sir momma Dee our office
and I'm not sure but it looked like
Magnus was consulting with Randy on that
last decision are they allowed to do
that I don't think so Matt are we
looking for a little help
I heard from you me too much yet what
are your thoughts about this experience
I believe it's your first time oh you
did play that's right you didn't make
any blunder so I don't remember no I
mean I think we're doing great so far
especially around this play I think it's
been as good as any other member of the
team so it's important part in our
victory so let's see how it goes Wow oh
so good team member Lanier's and Randy's
play else on the team
itself to me like babbys the weak link
thus far I mean blundering that pawn in
game one right Christian no absolutely
on that was yourself don't be small
unforgivable mistake yeah all this
preparation for ultimate moves and it
all comes down to a blunder of upon by
the Challenger I'm shocked night eight
three visit he was happy to make such a
move do you think we're going to see
more of a Randy erect so this baby maybe
an extra turn oh yeah well it's a slow
manner boom we made fires I was about to
say slow maneuvering no more slow
maneuvers after that move once again
very inviting very inviting move
potentially 95 Queen b3 I like that i
watch the bishop be safe from the threat
they should be snakes
no no Queen c7 or something like that
he'll back up or what else is there
I think his intention had been to faith
in you guys I think he's considering it
yeah yeah to sacrifice the pawn and get
a mission and he's done it he's done it
I can see we're in a tight fitting shirt
like that one Hawaiian shirt what do you
think Rex satisfied with his open
position with the black pieces
I think he's satisfied yeah I mean I
like home I'm in the clock I guess black
is using a lot more time than white they
get big problems
the thing feels strong back in you want
to give them a lot of Christian exactly
but this move rook mediator sent I think
say that before
yes that's what I mean you need to think
very modest move at age three he's ready
to go out for and controlling the squirt
in chief nice and wide c4 popping and I
thought rook c2 was the move to stop
this midnight c4 but LaVon I said that
he didn't need to play
either the theme is rich in intense what
are your thoughts um yeah this this one
we probably because I haven't played yet
we seem to be doing a little better than
are you excited by this kind of position
well I'm hoping all the work will be
done by the time they support Bishop b5
exchange that light square bishop and
then attack the poor but we have
survived you realize the sing fields
will be back sorry your as the sing
fields will be back yeah but we have
space advantage so I think Randy likes
to have enough space players suggest
Sasha
going under the 2-minute mark Oh Oh big
trouble so it heart the rube have to be
square them interesting move because not
if you think on c4 I'm going to take you
home first
that was the trick I think that was a
dream what if we just take the bishop
and then take a point on a on a yeah I
think that's an extra point
Oh actually you have root k4 to regain
the pawn on e6 exactly he's done it he's
taken the bishop he's taken the pawns
we're okay for as you prescribed who's
next
h5 was a surprise
[Music]
any major piece of a queen trader or
trade we use to loosen chances in the
position so inspecting look to see the
intensity of the players they know this
is a crucial part of any a streak I see
like black to be honest like thing is
safer the can you see that is good but
without the roof could be a problem when
the sink build step in Randy and then we
have one minute than you're 23 seconds
fourteen breaths Randy started with the
white pieces and si to my rosy by and
another t-rex black out plate what
exactly
still no weaknesses you know Randy's
safe I want both rights the DVR safe I
said no right
if the position gets a bit too
complicated but then we can discuss but
right now there's no weaknesses I'm
considering g4 but I like to move g4 to
give your King a little space there it
is and there it is
you can set up with your queen on e to
your King on TV when you gotta focus
yes mixed feelings about this move
though considering the fact that Randy's
becoming in complexity rampant the
higher which is bold well it's very much
in style of MA maxime when when he is
injured well I think it's you'll be in
soon after the Singh field yeah well it
hasn't exploded yet still pretty quiet
go ahead her a minute t-mike's Rex and
Randy are going to be under the gun in
no time Randy who's now thinking wow
that's pretty fast does my mean they
both do that's usually not when g46
quickly by Rex Sinquefield
no H for now because of that extra H
pawn and the position for white we'd
like to move H for this Christian is
suggested will Randy find it and you see
Randy robbing his hands you know
confidence little gleeful expression in
his face and he's done wow wow I
couldn't figure out I think the Grand
Master's are at AA that's why they're so
quiet
King edge figs good news well played my
post
yeah Randy comes up with money
there's been a trade weedy sakes you
gotta be careful then you can just see
the point well will he just a the pond I
was about to say I think he was afraid
that his King was gonna get exposed I
think we'd have severed his name over
right now yes sir
we'd have seven to be a checkmate on the
boat he's played queen g4 when we made
on g6 there are a potential I think this
is Rex's last move don't blow checkmate
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
Magnus if you keep following all his
good moves I know it's the best job
there is Randy you must feel awesome you
want it twice for your team I can't
believe we have such a solid lead I'm a
lot more comfortable hope Gary's
watching at home very very far far from
here Rex you took that one on the chin
how's it feeling I don't want to talk
about it
well team Rachel's gonna have to come
back they're down Oh to where there's
still four games to play so we'll see
what they can do
Thank You Maurice Oh Oh where's the
training what have you done to our Rex
poor Jennifer our standings it's Oh to
team Randy on top big comeback needed
for Iraq's and with the white pieces
that's get him the pressures on oh no
question about it and I mean Randy's has
been playing great I mean he found some
really cool moves and Christian what can
you say I'm afraid though the broom is
ready guys it's a we see a sweep for oh
it seems like team Rex is demoralized at
the moment despite the fact that Rex
played some pretty decent moves Randy
was just bouncing and bouncing and
playing amazing moves creating threats
absolutely at every stage of the game
and I think that was key in this matchup
I'm looking forward to see whether team
Rex can bounce back and you've got the
key moment on the board behind you that
move f5 by MDL yes now for the game and
turned it around completely for yes
absolutely and I want to point out a
very important moment I'm trying to find
a move f5 there is in this position
white actually
this amazing tactic f4 now this pawn is
taboo because if you take it I'm going
to go Bishop to d4 I'm going to give a
double attack and your queen is going to
be lost instead of that you can
potentially play the move Bishop f6 but
now unfortunately after g5 your Bishop
it has run of the space he doesn't have
anywhere to move and he's going to be
lost White is going to be winning but of
course you know the look at this lineup
of talent very very very very kicked off
alright well we have a situation Randy
is up to oh the team Rex will have to
come back Peter what is it gonna take
well possibly playing somewhat better
but I'm not sure our goal is to win the
next big game and let's get Alex what
are your thoughts on how you doing so
far and them winning the next three not
gonna happen alright those are fighting
words let's get started and they're
underway for Game three of the ultimate
moves and another were Lopes why not I
think is what we're gonna see there's a
b5 indeed has been really practicing
it's like what's gotten into big Bobby
Fischer fans
[Music]
[Music]
yeah that's
[Music]
evil intentions on the long diagonal
yeah
20 moves told us infield stuff that goes
20 moves plenty of time for them to be
decided this is a very sharp position by
Shakur three wins there yeah
[Music]
five on the menu Bishop c5 Wow
Oh for white yes like this night works
what about the g8 like you
that was a really clever move by Hikaru
are you defending the g6 pawn to f5 is
possible also just thing with the two
bishops
[Music]
was enticing oh my god yeah big very
much down to their last two minutes and
unicorns are real if two things are come
on you seem quite pleased with this
position yeah which is worth a queen
they're talking about the cool
physicians and equal opportunities okay
like this and then I play like this yes
[Music]
but they won't resign but wait so the
same folks definitely no tracks you're
so wonderful that's our okay think about
the presiding officer
let's just do this what's happening yeah
where's the Disciplinary Committee
speaking of arbiters Chris bird tweeted
at us
I am us I misspoke earlier and he said
something about how it'll mean it takes
two times to make Emilio move to get
forfeited Ron I'm not sure we'll be set
on the right just like we'll get you a
penalty
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
we step in we get really positions with
the white beef you know fight for the
advantage you think he's getting some
secret world champion preparation yeah
thing you work with Jeff big just before
coming here look at rex games and no
really rec space the real opeth you
think Rex's games are actually I think
we're looking at an upwards trend to
bishops maybe we can throw that right
31 bishops of the same color shark
attack doesn't seem to know stuff we
should take C to D then put the bishop
on
what we are not playing for defend we're
trying to make yeah maybe some people
deficient
it's for thinking
no choice here I think we have any more
moves before I Randy and Lex that means
that's right this will be the 33rd move
to this moving to more for life in the
position very complex for me I think
that's what the track is going instance
he's banking on the next one is rice but
but very little time for team racks 30
seconds left and he's for the checkmate
oh that's a terrible move those yes
linear from Bishop c5 check that was I
think it's a reputation this time for no
Rex has got to come in and now it's
Randy I think they're off I move takes
wins of the ship or even pawn takes a
ball ship that's a very safe option
brand is amazing and I think he's going
for that for oh he was young extremely
upset last trip what if you remember yes
there was a pie break right seven games
instead of six because the manager went
to break and there goes upon this should
take a great play by Randy the checks
are ineffectual the king will just go
back
we're gonna pretend we were mercilessly
flagged explaining he's got the best job
in the world coming in after team Randi
I'm not upset about this yeah I'm not
I'm not upset about this position I'm
upset about my previous choices life
choices in manner it seems like
everybody's pointing at you as the goat
that's yeah yeah can I can I sort of tag
you in and I can I you speak some
English I can maybe you know do your job
and you can do mine because I obviously
can't can do this anymore
well you're gonna have to there's that
Oh three hold you guys aren't I'm aware
yeah and this one is largely on me I
think I think 9 g5 was inexcusable all
right well we will see how it fares in
the next three games as team Randy has
galloped ahead with three big wins as
Magnus said he's got the best job in the
world he comes in when it's mop-up time
we will see how the rest of the games
transpire Thank You Maurice - impressive
Randy really set him up well - you know
just calculating it to a victory mama
Dee are trying to mix it up but too
little too late you're a nurse or oh
three brutalization
that's right team Randy crushing a can
Rex and his teammates salvaged the match
and win the next game they meet
we need to sell a salvage some pride oh
and three Christian horrifying
horrifying no absolutely I was a team
Rex at the beginning but right now it
becomes obvious Randi definitely spent
this past year preparing for this moment
and he's just delivering to be honest
Rex cannot be blamed in this one he got
a losing position when he entered the
fray the second time and you know Randy
executed him
you know he was just I think Peter was
right this 95 is a little bit too
ambitious and after d5 actually the
computer likes black already better
because you get 94 you get the
initiative white doesn't have
development and black is just going to
have a very comfortable game I think
this is what Peter was referring to so
we'll see I am this one is not looking
good I think Tim Randy is going to close
the show and deliver the suite has has
this ramifications for the world
championship as Debbie's confidence is
the most important tournament of the
summer of chess it's just so painful
pink oh yeah those shots when you need
them
Fabiano and Peter and the whole team
there have to do some real
soul-searching after this game and as
Peter the goat although why do they keep
bringing in Peter to resign the goat is
supposed to be the greatest of all time
right well yeah they bring in the guy to
resign I mean they wheel them in and say
please this case is kind of fair because
that is a tough opening to play in a
blitz game where you have two amateurs
playing you know it gives black the
initiative and white sucked up so much
time on the pot exactly so Peter think
you believe in that one farad officers'
yeah bring it back for Team rats well
we're gonna get started with Game four
well it's o3 and the team rax has done
some soul-searching as you said Bobby
you were giving Wrexham advice before
this round what were your thoughts with
him well I told Rex that since we're in
a must-win for the next three games that
we should mix it up a bit so hopefully a
strategy will pay off
you're not afraid he's gonna make a big
mistake early I think at this point it
doesn't matter you know you got fennel
ofin from all right Rex time to teach
Randy a lesson Randy you look guys
please this punch I feel great I was
just wondering if somebody get give him
a coaster it's like this guy thinks he
owns the place Thanks you know we got
him exactly where we want him they're in
the lead and overconfident we got him
well with that let's get started I must
say Rex look really tough ready to mix
it up they played see for the first
white game right black got a really nice
position though so Randy I guess decided
to switch it hop that's what I'm saying
he's ready for every single situation he
has before I love I love it not really
because there's a knight on f3 right
usually you want to play F horse
remind the lien magnets in the position
where he doesn't have to accept
resignation do a little work
so it's pretty much disposing into some
sort of a pawn on e6 g6e file takes
takes and a six Queen of three and it's
already Rex making a challenge wager but
you didn't Sandra's betting them a
hundred dollars okay blunder
[Music]
do you think they stand a chance to turn
things around 3-0 is huge that's a
mountain I think it was 3-1 actually
last time last year
yeah then they came back and actually
won no it was 3-1 racks Randy won the
last one
oh yeah he almost made me to come back
he's 75 and this sure does look like
Guru Lopez by transposition now a closed
room with black getting some extra moves
in actually yeah because he wanted
actually your bishop
has that blonder no he didn't even
bother to think about taking the e4 pawn
I thought it might have been a blunder
of a pawn
because we're not a piece up yet Peter
hoping to redeem himself he has thus far
that was a good move easier for the
commentators theater right remember who
you represent so now the knife has to be
rerouted for probably g3 is so the
problem is Bishop f1 is preparing them
of g3 because play g3 with the pitch
pony tooth a string hands
here we go where we'll be seeing night
afore I think so he's reaching for it
he's done it yes big guy move instantly
answered with 92 by the way is the night
going to be free or not the question
some sacrifices made I like me might be
a bit getting in a little trash-talking
moment he's amazing at destabilizing how
much good it did me I think the best
thing to do in this position is just to
take and
[Applause]
a good chance oh you to throw some
patties
it's needed desperately needing a
victory committee back into this match
the down position is one of the most
intense and rich so far what do you
thought well we're already having a
debate whether blacks should already
start trying to mate or or try to take
it slow I like the way that Wesley's
playing that he's taking it solely
enjoying his position the smile from
Wesley slower hasn't been paying off for
a lot they have to go forward to
checkmate exactly let's go age 5 gm that
has to be played you wanna reach him
Peters today Wesley is about safety he's
reaching for that age sure I mean that's
the money move there it is there it is
he couldn't resist he had to go can
check the backs against the wall let's
face it you got to go for for the
checkmate you need that morality 3 you
need the crushing dude
exactly and now we're waiting for
further advance and he's done it
there we four do you recapture with the
bishop though that's a good question yes
or no yes
now one interesting movies actually
it was just this will be wisely laughing
and Sergei
[Laughter]
kicked out we expected Sergey and I
changed lineups on us Jennifer can they
do that where's the arbiter let me get
away with that allowed it nothing to
think about you can't take with the
bishop there's a night for con d3
letting the game flow yeah I think we
need a well compensated appeals
committee I think we're great candidates
for that
precisely okay now how to prosecute the
attack what a troll and the match
basically exactly aimlessly it was a
very generous offer respect Michigan
joined the fact that it's his opponents
whose clock is ticking down right maybe
eight or so I think in this movie
didn't see a clear way to prosecute the
attack lady to check what's this choice
the question is what was the follow-up I
think you just go back or I may play ot8
you have to be sure that the rookie
since that's a good question because the
night on f4 was ready to jump on d3
might say this drop in and not for
another eight moves there is one big
time move knight on c6 to d4 that may
yet turn the tide all kinds of tactics
on the long diagonal like that yeah
that's up Chuck's alley
yeah he sees the tactics as he knows he
said himself is a tempo against the
Queen no time to drop in with the night
snack no realizing he's gotta play fast
we need really Queen f6 it's really
burned a lot of clock in these last but
no Queen if squeezed actually no Bishop
c5 still they're very quiet in the
peanut gallery yeah cuz it's the most
interesting position we've had so far
and so little time on the clock deciding
game yeah where we want to make it clean
like when the score represents the real
difference between the talent in the
teams
you've been waiting for Livan to get in
his trash-talking he's not disappointing
us g3 plays trapping the night and
tuning the night on e - it's got no
escape but can you attack it but almost
equalizing the part the the time is
Grisha who spent a lot of time in the
last few moves Bishop h6 i wanna Knight
d4 was the trick he's getting ready to
put the knight on c1 and jump back
reroute it to d3 you know that's why I
thought the bishop might be better best
served on the e3 the biggest have been a
star so far you keep setting Randy up
with fantastic situation and he executes
them though Jay exactly those are our
one-two punch will Dominguez do it again
in this difficult situation set Randy up
for a nice clean sweep LaVon said but
for the first time again I said it
earlier in this game but it really seems
like this was the first time that team
Randy is getting lower on the clock and
he rocks
that's an amazing move we'd like this
rule because it side steps they should
see one kind of ideas and it as I said
it outcomes they should see one okay I
think the King is a little more ball on
h1 no he's played Bishop III nobody's
back but now maybe I can just simply
take and he has I mean the two infantry
g4 is hanging that c3 would be hanging
yes Queen c2 also the bishop on c2 would
be hanging yeah I think Queen d2 already
does a check of a 35 35 seconds for both
players approximately 39 when Randy and
Rex get in it would be crazy he's done
it well if you go Queen eight I'm
willing to go King g7 you take the night
and then
Queeny one queen takes F two queen g1
checkmate
exactly two more minute to two memos for
each player night upon late-night f1
first Queen c3 now you go check and that
variation no longer works when you take
nobody
Willie take the knight will he take the
knight
you're right it's been a one-two punch
thus far he's not going for he's
reaching for it I swear he was reaching
for his queen
top spot for Randy was the first one on
move cuz he's gone down to it I mean
exquisite form by Randy sing feel
throughout this Queenie one no
government moves he has to play the
teammates were excited about that
[Music]
[Music]
they both what a game though this Rex
well Rex the comeback is on you got your
chance this time the steel the queen how
does it feel it was wonderful redemption
is great everybody was so quiet they
felt like this was potentially the
deciding game but you guys stop the
trend well you know as this thing was
developing I'm saying holy cow I got to
sit down in 5 or 6 News and I'm not sure
I have any idea what's going on if
there's a complicated position and I
didn't see how to make progress and
suddenly your thing opened up I saw the
knight move at night was well-placed in
that square and I was I really don't
know what else could even we didn't drop
his queen he's gonna drop the piece so
we were in good shape
alright good comeback for the team now
it's 3 2 1 can they continue the trend
we'll see in the next game well that was
a nail-biting finish Jennifer I mean my
goodness everything up for grab what's
our standard well it's great for team
rat Rex says he's got one point to a
Randy's three so there's gonna need to
win the next two games to tie up the
match and then we'll see what happens in
that case but they avoided the sweep
this is important I mean with a nice and
with a nice win by rocky played it I
mean the confidence is bursting right
no absolutely fantastic that was the
best game of the match in my opinion I
mean the tension in infused in this in
this game was amazing and I want to give
it to a Kuryakin because this
infiltration with a move Queen to d2 I
think was key Queen to d2 night wave one
Queen takes c3 grabbing this almost
poisoned pawn but after Queen e8 King g7
Queen takes c6 this key move Knight d4
we attribute that to Rex and amazing
victory after right before black is
already better if you move the Queen I'm
going to take back the bishop and now
you're going to have some problems
because of the pawn on c4 which is going
to run down the board
and become a queen so amazing amazing
play by team rex congratulations and we
avoided a sweet thank you Kristian and
ultimate moves is not the only feature
that's going on here in st. Louis this
summer no that's right this is a warm-up
for our crown jewel of the grand chest
or the same field cup the classical
event of the tour it's gonna be taking
place from August 18 to 28 August 17 is
the opening very nice and I the books
are in town for that we got the sink
build cup the commemorative books of
five years of st. Joe Cup and Magnus
Carlsen a wild card will be our one of
the featured players Manchester regulars
at the first ever seen field Cup
campaign he just arrived into town he
drops in for the most important event of
all yeah three one it looks like they
were discussing their next game strategy
their pre match pregame warmup talk and
I was just gonna say this sink fill cup
is an extra special one because unlike
previous Grantchester [ __ ] what we're
doing is we're getting the top four
players of the grand chat those four
players who have won the most grand
chests or points will go to London to be
playing elimination matches for the
Grantchester championship title I love
this format yet it adds so much drama -
who's gonna come to the top floor
exactly and so that's what we're gonna
be following missing folk up not just
the winner of the Sinquefield Cup which
is an incredible story in its own right
well we have a repeat winner a brand-new
winner right but also who's going to
London so we're gonna be following two
things it was right it's a tournament
within the tournament so two pairs
because the players are jockeying for
position in Christian I mean as Jennifer
said it so well herself it's the crown
jewel of chess in America no absolutely
and we're going to see the big match
between Magnus
and Fabiano on the 25th of August Magnus
already is said to have the white pieces
so he's definitely going to try to be a
trendsetter and and put a lot of
pressure on probably on with the white
pieces set up the pace for the match in
November Nakamura he's already almost
qualified because he's just had an
amazing year in the Grantchester
he's very few points a way of
guaranteeing his spot in London if I'm
not mistaken and but besides him there's
a lot of players battling for those
spots let's go to Maurice and start the
fifth round of the ultimate news well
the score is 3 1 or 1 3 depending on
what side you're looking at it from
Randy you could have sealed the deal
that game but dad came back and stole
the Queen yeah you know where time
trouble it was tricky but he's a
generous guy so I feel like I owed him a
little charity right I have to confess
with admiration that Randy's playing
quite well today you've been quite
impressed you don't say that very often
but you know I'm a truth teller all
right all right well let's see you the
excitement continues as team Randy tries
to finish them off let's get started
Randy they're changing the strategy yes
eat no more eat this whole 636 that easy
play for my surprise what I so excited
such a great position with the white
piece usually were fighting for quality
struggling to survive it's a good sign
field we're gonna win our second game
now you really have that kind of
confidence in your teammates oh yeah of
course
even after their play I'm always all
right well the trash-talking in joy has
started on the other side
Levon your thoughts I think that's a
very distant opening for black we have
developed both of our Knights man Liam
Castle we have our bishop out so we're
controlling the center fighting back I
don't know where they're so happy about
Magnus is giggling through it all as he
realizes he's actually in a worse
position and just listening to his
teammate explain why they have such a
new position EMBL enjoying his position
appreciate Queen 814 quickly Jenna
that's right they realize they should
keep up with the clock that will happen
like in last game it was kind of going
back and forth but in the end
Bradley actually lost on time yeah he'd
blur this Queenie but yeah a seven a six
is very quiet is doing for a fight
well whoa whoa awake b5 works it does
work because
the Queen that's sitting down enjoying
his position and now LaVon can explain
why Pakistan so well there is a 94 and
95 tempo let's see how LaVon handles it
so proud yeah puts the question is are
you gonna take my night the answer came
quickly with a yes he said well sharply
dressed even to be you see everybody
Domingues always and he's nothing on the
Olympic team throw you Peter destroy
your faith in humanity no let them date
live I've known you for ages I have no
longer any faith in humanity what so
[Music]
Peter don't let them
my teammates destroy your faith in man
I have no faith in humanity
Queen I'd sink 83 to the tail the night
may be in order a 2 a 3 stopping that
night from jumping maybe Peter has
different ideas I like that move the
question is what we're watching in
happen time in that situation for a
record
maybe 935 and I like our position once
again tried to go on but he chooses
Quincy whoa okay now I need to help
solicit every loose so bear with me in a
childish kind of way he's talking to his
opponent and say you good they're yours
because they're the tax might take the
a2 and base out there and how about this
[Laughter]
[Music]
he's done it
so the options are Quinton takes these
six No
remember night they say - is awkward
before also if yes if you play three
actually night a - is great it's
actually quite awkward to defend of just
take on c7 no played a three in a tree
defending the pawn on a - and it's a
kind of semi pin of the night and if you
go be sure to d5 continue the attack on
the pony - maybe you can play b3 b3 then
we treat the Queen on rb2
and have a normal position and there's
also a move to keep in mind rook c5 is
the potential looking at Bishop f33 and
Queen T for ideas and I Snapple upon
wishes a chess legend and the pawn
rubber but c7 will be hanging again he's
done it
not bothering with the complicate
complications but the immediate rook c7
was Bobby's choice almost 20 months
never be an internal frame the action is
intense as team Randy leads three two
one and team wrecks desperate draw
that's history especially in the
position because it looks quite equal
exactly
viviana was an intense situation again
order your thoughts
I think we're pressing and I think that
love clearly rattled bishi because of
his last move why so oh I just don't
think 95 was the best room in the
position a be getting a little
trash-talking saying that Vichy was
rattled before chopping down before
Queen is gonna come to be three love
those tempo moves right Jen
there you see we're going to see most
probably a five White has a Catalan type
of it advantage something that that
Wesley will be very pleased the power of
the bishop over tonight Haven was rapid
and blitz champion in Paris Grantchester
order back back-to-back victories I
think it was at the closing ceremony
that he Carlos said he's looking forward
to back to back to back victories and
Gary Kasparov who he missed today at
ultimate lose did also compliment and
congratulate he's back more on his
back-to-back wins yes Gary on his annual
vacation and Croatia
sending is a greetings through Michael
corn Akatsuki who's here representing
the she's part of chess foundation we've
I don't recall ever seeing this
intensity without Gary Kasparov in the
building why is that well the last two
years have been very tense I mean at
some point in the previous game it felt
like every move you had to think without
blundering something or allowing some
tactic and so at some point all of us
just wait and the clock was running down
as well and I was hoping for an easier
game this time but again it's gonna be
tense but Randy is getting us very solid
stuff this time
gotta win this one or go go to the next
one it could be really dead
well you never plan for going to the
next one I'm not sure about this move
Queen d3 by by by Wesley he's kind of
setting up himself up for some tactical
backfires with this move Queen b3 I
don't think that was necessary
Queen a6 that was a dangerous position
by you he had to play six I think
loosey-goosey they're lucky then the
thing field on coming in for another 10
moves we need six three wasn't on there
yeah it feels wrong and he knows his
plane Wesley knows it a blunder but no
material oh you mean the BT upon the
whites advantage would be a neutral mark
is the point here and in fact it seems
that more things are hanging in White's
position then before this matters a lot
he's our anchor two-time situation
that's very important was a shock even
Sasha Gray shook was like what look at
his eyes what is that you were talking
about anchored pieces the night was
nicely defended and then came a fine
Christian was that a he's trying to go
he for his fingers not so much he's
trying to displace the bishop on our f3
whoa we be free from a strategical point
of view this thirty three seconds left
and the Queen's have traded and things
are intense now Ruby final you have
black has got to come up with a good
idea
mystics is stepping back attack
maybe before not possible because we
could take with the pod well you can do
it
yeah the bishop defenders change
dramatically like what about them but
now it's intent yeah well maybe he car
was trying to keep it interesting but
now we have some new hope they know how
this works
play fast let this thing get a little
bit of breathing room
Rex is Lori you can see it as an
expression there guys it's coming down
to black should play your b3 I'm
thinking 494 Wow
that's lazy that's playing with fire
right as if there was no problem though
this is the last 94
Oh correct right coming in with this
time ticking and I like that needing a
win
can't allowing a droid to go King at
three in a repetition might just do it
he has to be Randy okay okay exactly and
you defend the pawn on f2 and
counter-attack the pawn on f7 I wasn't
looking there's a nice sequence whoa g6
by Randy was that 43 plate rook f3 was
this choice not f4 Madinah tempo would
have been better yeah exactly
still is over k2 there is that the chief
I thought okay no betrayed the rooks oh
it is Wow MDL taking the hot seat and
then you please remove him from the
board okay
Magnus actually has to do some more he
saw his clock is ticking 94 Magnus
this would be the end there was some
very complicated right yeah
quickly
well they better players are rotating
quickly you have five is an idea because
you don't have the check on the thief
thing I'm a little surprised that what
black just didn't put his rook on d3 and
not the f3 pawn eyeball
Bobby poaching rats yeah this is the way
we wouldn't look endings Rex you're
right yeah fine and black is forced back
a little bit on the defensive he's going
to give up check on that side he came
back and I look up see he did it
inviting a king upon endgame he's got it
all worked out to a draw though keep the
game going exactly but now how many
moves we have I think we just got that
Shaq himself how many moves
thank you thank you Equipe Sergei there
you felt now king we're taking the
passing road and when Rex is playing
amazing yeah even though white is for
choice checking the White King actually
there is no easy scheme the
[Applause]
what a great game just amazing
Rex you gave it your best shot but your
son defended like monster yes he did
they were tough today
you know c'est la vie c'est la guerre
Olivier do la femme song Cher well as
you complete touch everybody else
understood that reference how do you
feel seriously about losing this year
well it's tough but they played well
Randy played well I was proud of what he
did Randy you got him back thanks dad I
appreciate that really yeah it's been a
long time coming
last year was especially painful so
feels good to to get a win I think these
guys this incredible team of mine drinks
on me tonight guys we all heard that is
it next year already all right well the
score is three and a half one and a half
but there is one more game just for fun
I'm sure bragging rights is important so
we'll set up for that one and finish off
this day all right well thank you buries
that is unexpected I thought that had
ended the match but you know there
aren't and the players are under
contract
one more game very important and this is
our scoring one and a half three and a
half so Randy has
smack but we're gonna play one more fun
game so hopefully it'll be like the high
quality ones we just saw exactly and
Christian for the confidence I mean I
absolutely think team Rex needs to get
one back no absolutely and to be honest
they've been playing amazing chess all
of them you know all the players
including Rex and Randy they find the
best moves in the position at least in
the past two games and it seems like a
team Rex is warming up and I'm expecting
a very combative last round despite the
fact that they're not playing for
anything significant nevertheless
we're going to have a lot of fun and
let's take a look at the GCT standings
as we're getting set up for them
America's crown jewel well para Nakamura
has got 33 grand chest to our coins good
for at least a $90,000 we've also got
MDL Sergei cardiac and Wesley so in that
final four going to London it's a
20-minute did right now but with lavon
and Shaq and so many grand chests or
points up for grabs in the synchro cup I
feel that those top six players have
great chances I mean just the just
because Wesley so is in fourth place
doesn't mean he doesn't have to look
over shoulder and see Shaq and LaVon
it'll be very intense in the sync Hioki
coming up
obviously the keeps
first round on August 18th and don't
forget that epic matchup averse Kurata
and Carlton that will be in the 25th
Saturday all very very very nice so
we've got a lot to look forward to as we
get ready for our final game of the
ultimate moves and so much on the line
wladim bragging rights and you know how
it goes and tomorrow is the opening
right and we've got the book signing
along with the players for those of you
are going to be in town here in st.
Louis that's right
over at King side diner there will be a
general signing as well as a book
signing for the Sinquefield cup book
that we co-authored along with Maurice
Alejandro impactive it's not good I mean
I'm anxious to see it I haven't even
seen it but let's go to Maurice for the
start of the final game of play well the
players are relaxed more or less as the
match has been decided but we know the
last game you don't want to lose even
after you win a match so there's gonna
be some bragging rights on the line
Randy how you gonna stay intense for
this game knowing you've already won the
match I'm calm now this should be easy
smooth sailin and right I beat what he
said this is gonna be smooth sailing
well somebody's gonna be unhappy after
this game so let's get it started
and English opening
and back to the play of a previous game
where at night after E and D for was
played that led to the new ropes he
bought it seems the game is heading in
the same direction night well 3 we're
getting to see the corn coming to d3 23
he mistimed it to get in the d4 yes and
of course is that completely losing that
is the question that feels completely
even Queen b6 potentially could be an
idea just control the d4 square
see here's a insight magnus carlsen is
in a bad position at the moment but does
he have an expression of a man worried
or not not with that smile
he's a the results focused individual
and they already want manager I think
this is just a relic station interested
you know what's up with the pickle sure
what kind of pickles is he promoting
them it's a show I think yes a tricky
part
this is improve tomorrow because the
pawn is on c4 so well that mr. Han that
Randy gambit
except to take it
Bishop checking we see my check
Oh William I their beauty that was
missed by
how do it in the mating attack scaring
another group before they publishing
this DVDs advertising beautiful them and
saying that thanks above it it has been
feeding you for so long you and your
family extended so he wants to make a
draw yet okay what can I do
what is begging for a draw
computer that has DVDs on how to play
the goon film okay those are on Ches 24
that's good
soon he will be begging further there is
such thing some dark square issues with
the fact that she wants blacks
advantages dissipating that he's got a
pocket he does have a pawn but he
doesn't have a mobility kiss - I'm
thinking rook e8 with the King looking a
big Savannah - we like there is an a7
phone also hello looking at this place
you have to be happy
yes
okay also I think at some point white is
going to consider taking only seven
think directly but at something there is
a real deep water terrible-looking those
indeed the question keeping some pieces
on the board maybe trying to get oh I
get one extra I'm not trying to take
only seven but I am kind of trying
something else you know what I mean
no not as great a player as you are yeah
not but there are some ideas I see he
got scared
those ideas are indeed frightening a
better structure because we're lacking
upon so the structure Journal is better
yeah I mean he wants to draw what can I
do left seems to be really finding the
way we didn't think about just exactly
and not in a good way
explaining that because he's a pawn down
the structure is improved yeah you have
more open files more positive away and
we have been traded it's usually a sign
you don't have to worry about
checkmating attacks anymore and it's all
about game play good move h5 like it put
the majority to work push him baby at
1607 wesley seems to be enjoying his
position is she less so
serious even though the mattress claims
team rats once they get that two and a
half yesterday to lose the final and
that actually that last game between
Hikaru and MVL allowed the MDL to bridge
the gap at Magnus is only three points
away from him in the live reading Liz
Wow in blitz
29:39 if I'm not mistaken for our Magnus
and 29:36 or MBO well I must say it's
great to have magnets back in town just
palpable excitement in the air here at
the club with his presence now that your
wife's gone who's gonna smile is gonna
light up the room as does event I'm
putting a lot of pressure on Fabian your
little almost two year old he's got a
gorgeous fine especially when I gave him
that chocolate chip cookie yesterday I
mean it was a bonding experience
especially when he bit my finger
7c file plate on the seat file
Peter you finally had a chance to play
in one of these and not be a commentator
now that disappearance is almost over
what are your thoughts I think I played
in definitely one maybe two of the
previous once again so yeah but somehow
I I think I dragged the team down a
little bit but this game this game we're
in control sadly the I mean it's it's
only a consolation game but thanks we're
hearing a beeping happening
yes it did you did play I remember now
not not after as a commentator though
but instead just as a player in the
event that two times you play in the
sink choked up so do you feel like
you're commentating skills might have
dragged down your playing skills I feel
that maybe this this display kind of
explains why I'm these days not
considered to be a great team player
because I get too nervous and too you
know worried about letting the letting
the side down which ends up letting the
side down and LaVon starts talking
didn't affect you know I I have met him
before so this this not news no no
sticking down right now well now that
the point is on d6 there is a lot of
life scores around him he wrecks his
position looks like is slipping slipping
like it's impossible for him to have an
interview without having some insights
of great philosophical his fear of
dragging the team drop down leads to
dragging the team down he's going to
corral around that pawn we should be
1726 and now he's going tried to invade
on c5 or potentially get his majority
going with f5 and d4 is a great block
hater and the king is all more active on
e6 than d7 maybe you wanna move to h8
look to h5 look to f5 could potentially
be and I know one of the things I'd love
to do before doing everything is
securing and batting down the hatches I
love this move g5 no week no H full-on
weakness anymore and this looks like
that technical victory in store here for
good luck this thing feels prepared to
jump in next move I believe and that's
why the bishop is such a great fall
cater they can just jump out as well it
should be five it they should be jumping
in right now with trepidation super
Genomes want to keep playing I mean
there we have it Wrexham field and Randy
Singh field art bat and Rex is ready to
double the rook you taught him to double
the rocks on the south exactly did you
know he knows all about those
checkmating threats when the rooks get
down whoo-hee move the bishop take the
pawn and press the clock with the other
hand it's generally considered not good
tables table side manners for the last
game the score final score three and a
half two and a half final thoughts Rex
on the match it was tense and Randy
played well everybody played well it was
exciting Randy
it didn't matter much but he did catch
her in the last game yeah I'm not
playing well in time trouble I don't
think I've ever found myself in that
position before so two major blunders
with seconds on the clock so I'll have
to work on that are you blaming your
teammates for that no no not at all no
that was me
it was all my mother's final thought on
the match vichy it's always a fun match
every time this year I think Randy
shouldn't take the hit of heat for this
one was pretty bad when we gave it but
no great and
really worked on his chess so that's
really good to see he gets better and
better
well we had a fun you everyone hope you
did too ultimate moves all these great
players before the Sinquefield comp
which will start in a couple of days
Thank You Maurice and thank you players
that was a fun outing I kinda feel like
the first few games were like a warm-up
and they played so well and those like
last three or four days that is the
final result Randy has won after three
years where he lost he came back Rex
Sinquefield a tough to lose but he's
also proud of his Simon yeah well I mean
the three and a half two and a half sort
of score I think basically best reflects
how competitive the the match was but it
was just that they got into such a hole
at the start final match thoughts
Christian well I had a lot of fun being
here with you guys and letting Maurice
take the live action for once and yeah
what an exciting match Randy definitely
came prepared for this one and the
results show so I'm looking forward to a
single Cup the next one the big one and
we're going to see a preview of the
match in November on August 25th so stay
tuned thank you very much and yeah sir
it was a pleasure as always as always
and for once I think the the games from
the ultimate moves especially the
opening we might actually see them in
the same field God okay there was some
high-level openings there um but first
up for the Sinquefield Cup festivities
is going to be an opening ceremony that
will be live streamed tomorrow that's
gonna be at 6:30 local time here on st.
Louis so 7:30 on the East Coast August
17th Sinquefield cup will kick off do
not miss it
thanks for watching thank you everyone
enjoy the rest of your day
[Music]